denise will have three new locations to
get a covet 19 test clark county
announcing a new testing event
that begins next week at three locations
it is called the stop swab and go event
joe moeller
is live at fiesta henderson one of those
locations hi joe
hey that starts next week like you had
mentioned and it goes to
september 18th fiesta henderson is one
of the locations in addition to sam boyd
stadium
and texas station north las vegas health
officials earlier today said the cases
have been going down for weeks and this
will help continue that downward trend
in an effort to combat copin 19 more
tests are coming to the valley
it is all part of the stop swab and go
event 60 thousand tests will be done at
three locations in
14 days starting august 31st monday
through friday 6 a.m to 2 p.m
we are the first community to actually
ask to see receive additional tests
wednesday county officials said this was
made possible with the help from the u.s
department of health
and the state this is an opportunity to
have 60 000 additional tests
in our community understand today that
there's a lot of mixed messages out
there on what we're really doing for
testing i can tell you we've been very
consistent
to test about 5 000
a day on a regular basis health
officials say cases have been going down
for about a month now
councilwoman pamela goins brown says her
area is getting hit hard by the virus
she is happy testing is coming back to
texas station and north las vegas
three of the five zip codes were in my
ward specifically
that had higher numbers and that was
really concerning to me
no appointment is needed but it is
recommended all locations are drive
through and
testing is free
and testing at cashman center as well
as unlv those testing sites will
continue to be in operation that's a
separate program as far as testing for
this
appointments are not needed but they are
recommended you can find the link to do
so up on our website
newsnow.com sending back to you guys